ouais
bonjour monsieur voilà je me présente je
m'appelle obi wan kenobi
nous faisons du porte à porte mon ami et
moi afin de parler un petit peu la force
aux gens est ce que vous connaissez la
force par hasard ouais mais non vous
êtes sûr ok mais non c'est quoi le petit
délire n'y a aucun délit en fait on
regarde si vous avez assez de mehdi clos
rien dans le sens et si c'est le cas
cela veut dire que vous avez la force en
vous et si vous maîtrisez cette force
eh bien vous passez au niveau 1 qui
garantit la possession d'un authentique
sabre laser comme celui dont camarasa
les gars vous dérange besoin d aide
bon ils défoncent non un acquis non on
va pas aller défoncer sert à rien de ce
que de toute façon monsieur va nous
rejoindre alors non non vous allez pas
rejoindre ses clowns nous on vous
propose de rejoindre notre seigneur
jésus-christ 1
excusez du peu l'appareil mais en fait
ils ont des sabres laser et nous aussi
sérieux vous n'avez pas lu le fascicule
quand vous allez ccsa combats n'ont pas
bien voilà personne ne lit jamais le
petit fascicule vous rejoindrez les
représentants légitimes de dieu sur
terre et vous aurez un sabre laser
vachement stylet et est-ce que ça écrire
c'est que vous plage et comme les gros
bâtards chez nous monsieur la tresse à
la con est pas obligatoire oui le
cheveux super super tête on va comparer
les idées maître yoda jésus-christ
ouais mais nous on n'a pas été racheté
par disney oh
la quille dans les défenses et du coup
c'était vraiment vrai le coude et saint
nazaire
et oui c'est vrai de lire le fascicule
le stop stop déjà stop je prendrais
facile
oui tenez le nôtre aussi voilà fascicule
parfait comme ça je regarde ça de mon
côté que la force soit avec vous que
jésus-christ soit avec 20 que la force
que jésus que juste parce que j'ai pensé
à la formidable face à face non monsieur
g en plus mais c'est quoi encore bonjour
monsieur oui vous l'amabilité de
m'accorder un instant s'il vous plaît